it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the big
cultural stories of the day after that
we turn to fox news contributor back
from some well earned vacay raymond
arroyo ray while you were gone
biden was diagnosed with covet yeah i
noticed laura with all the negative
reports of biden's general health though
the white house is clearly trying to
reassure the public that even with covet
biden is fine he's still in charge on
friday they installed what appears to be
a security cam in his office and made
him lead a meeting
this is the 38th day in a row are you
feeling better
thank you guys let's move it out
that went well uh are they shooting that
on biden's blackberry laura did they
just tape it to the wall what is that
then today they were at it again biden
has never been
better
how are you feeling with kelvin
i'm feeling great you know i've had
two full nights of sleep all the way
through so i felt this nuzzle of my
dog's nose against my chest about five
minutes to seven so uh no but it is i'm
feeling good my voice is still raspy
uh i've had every morning
every afternoon
i mean every evening i get a full-blown
series of tests everything from
temperature to oxygen to the oxygen in
my in my blood my plan empowers atf
entire ages
to stop trafficking in firearms across
state lines
laura they're giving him plaque slovak
they should give him prevagen the poor
man he needs holes or something he's
coughing he's he's out of it but this is
what happens when you're at 37
approval laura you've got to keep
pushing him out there and this is anita
dunn's i guess uh
search and relief package for bob just
keep him walking
raymond remember when trump had covered
obviously he had to get to go to
bethesda the hospital was you know yes
not good
but my goodness they made such a big
deal every time he was near anybody or
he wasn't supposed to do anything but
are we supposed to believe nobody comes
into the room at all to kind of arrange
that biden figures out the camera all by
himself i don't believe that
hermetically sealed rooms lori i mean
what about the poor dog major is going
to get covered possibly anyway laura the
capital saw bizarre climate
demonstrators today staffers of
democratic house members cory bush
elon omar jamie raskin and others were
arrested when they occupied democratic
senator chuck schumer's office they were
demanding that their own party pass
climate policy this year after joe
manchin refused to sign their two
trillion dollar spending package six of
the aides were arrested and at the same
time in florence at the ufc gallery
climate protesters glued their hands to
a 540 year old botticelli painting i
guess defacement of cultural treasures
is the only way to get this message any
attention
couldn't they have just glued themselves
to some hideous contemporary art that we
don't care about i mean we actually care
about the botticelli thank you very much
all right now al gore
try to simulate i should say the man
known as the human dirigible tried a
similarly desperate tactic to push his
agenda raymond
you know the climate deniers
uh are
really in some ways similar to all of
those almost 400 law enforcement
officers in uvalde texas
who were waiting outside an unlocked
door
while the children were being mastered
they heard the screams they heard the
gunshots and
nobody stepped forward
laura this is so disgusting that he
would use a tragedy and these children's
death to push this old climate agenda
that he's never been right about by the
way in 2006 he
gore said and i quote if we don't reduce
carbon emissions in 10 years we will
have a planetary emergency al we're way
past your deadline stick to the things
we can really control
he is it just me or does he look
positively plasticine raymond i mean he
looked
he was uplit i mean believe me i can
have some bad days but he was uplit this
looked like something out of that
lighting yeah i wonder if he's
reflecting moonlight or something i
don't know what that is like that was an
odd
finally laura
i was on vacation last week as you
mentioned and i'm so grateful i was not
at disney world mickey's fill her magic
looked like mickey's fight club two
families got into a dispute in line
which they carried outside punches flew
a brawl ensued in front of children i
might add and a few of these kindly dear
people were arrested others were banned
from the park and asked to leave the
disney hotel
i think they should have gotten a
magical tase and everyone should have
been arrested bibbidi-bobbidi bale
that's what should have happened in this
season
yeah ryan this is a fast pass to fight
club i mean this is well did you
go ahead didn't you go to a different
theme park
i did we went to dollywood and i have to
tell you it was placid everybody had
such beautiful manners it was clean it's
what disney used to be in the 80s clean
family friendly people had a wonderful
time but the people who work there the
southern hospitality the kindness it was
everywhere it's a beautiful spot and
it's my first time in dollywood so uh i
see why people will always love her yeah
thanks for the invitation the ingrams
used to travel with arroyos
so cute you guys look adorable i'm glad
you had a good time raymond you deserved
a break great to see you as always great
to see you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else